>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> BARD Express: Transferring
materials to cartridge
>> Judy: Hi, I'm Judy Dixon
Consumer Relations Officer at NLS.
In this edition of the
BARD Express How-To Series,
I'm going to cover
transferring audio materials
to a cartridge or other
storage device.
From the BARD Express Main
Menu select bookshelf.
You will be presented with a list
of the types of materials that are
on your computer that you
have downloaded from BARD.
The contents of your bookshelf can
be sorted by Subject or Author.
Note that the default organization
is by Type, in alphabetical order,
followed by the number of titles
in each category: All Books
and Magazines, Audio
Books, Audio Magazines,
Read items, and unread items.
To sort your titles by subject,
select Subject from
the drop down menu.
All the titles on your
bookshelf will resort
by subject in alphabetical order.
To sort by author, select
Author from the drop down menu.
All your titles will resort
by author's last name
in alphabetical order.
In this demonstration we will go
back to titles sorted by type.
Select Unread items to access
the titles on your bookshelf
which you have not
transferred to a cartridge.
Choose the title you wish to read
and select the Copy
to Cartridge button.
A dialog box will open.
Choose the drive letter
that your cartridge
or USB flash drive is connected
to, and select the Ok button.
While the book is transferring,
BARD Express is locating
the downloaded title,
unzipping the file, and copying
the title to your cartridge.
No more unzipping files, no more
lost books on your computer.
BARD Express handles
all of this for you.
When the transfer is complete,
BARD Express will ask you
if you would like to
eject the drive.
Just say Yes and simply disconnect
the cartridge from your computer,
connect it to a digital
player, and enjoy your book!
For more information about
how to use BARD Express,
see the other videos in this series.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.